4-3 2008 is talk about Good People day
can we make this happen it was a very
special time on Twitter when I created
good people day years ago with this
video and it's funny that my idea was
about rewarding good behavior so much of
my themes gratitude optimism kindness
our continued themes a decade later for
me every day should be good people day
but April 3rd is good people day the
most underrated brand in the world
is the human being
we are much much much much much much
much
better than you think we are the problem
is the evening news has told us how bad
we are for the last 50 years I think
positivity and good is practical advice
to building an empire and I want to be
the poster child of the person that
built the biggest baddest
Empire and did it by being a good dude
along the way